Good morning John, hey, look!
It's Portland, Oregon, outside that window,
also in this hotel room, I guess?
I mean, what is space?
I'm up in the air, fourteen stories, and I'm
inside of a hotel room that is owned by, I
assume, a hotel chain.
But am I even in any of those places?
Am I not just in the space between my neurons?
Is that Portland?
Is that area between my neurons Portland just
because I am within the boundaries of the
city of Portland, Oregon?
Ugh.
As you can see just by the conversation I
just had with you I've been hanging out with
the creators of "Welcome to Night Vale", Joseph
Fink and Jeffrey Cranor.
The book just came out, debuted number four
on the New York Times best-seller list, number
four because Nicholas Sparks, J.K.
Rowling, and John Grisham came out with new
books this week.
Bad week to try and get to number one.
I was with Jeffrey and Joseph when they got
the news that they were number four on the
New York Times best-seller list, and that
was a great experience for me not only because
the Chinese crepes from the Portland food
cart we were eating were amazing, but also
because it was good to see that happen to
a person.
I'm feeling thankful right now.
I'm feeling thankful for like three or four
things, uh, just great comments on the last
couple videos that we've made.
Remarkable how well-received my Benghazi video
was.
I received lots of hate, just to be clear,
but, like, the like-to-dislike-ratio was pretty
amazing, which makes me feel like there's
a lot of interest in this kind of content.
I mean, it doesn't go super viral.
Let's be honest: if my video was about getting
riled up and angry about one or the other
side, how wrong they were, how evil they were,
how they were trying to destroy America - and
that's literally the rhetoric that people
use in these conversations - it would have
gotten more views.
It would have made people want to stand up
on the mountaintops and shout to their people
and it would have gotten more than 300,000
views.
But!
300,000 views, it's a tremendous amount it's
the kind of influence that high-school or
college Hank could only have ever dreamed
of having!
So, what is the goal?
What is the important thing here?
That we use the platform we have to get more
views?
Grow a bigger platform, and then we use that
platform to grow a bigger platform and then
that bigger platform we can then use to grow
a bigger platform?
Is that the only goal?
At a certain point you have to say that, like,
doing things that you know, as a person, are
bad for individual people and culture as a
whole are not worth doing just to get a bigger
audience, and you use the platform you have,
and God am I thankful to have this platform,
to do something you think is good.
Making content that removes the charge, that
removes the fear, of the other fifty percent
of Americans from the political discourse,
that would be extremely valuable.
I also wanna say thanks to all the people
who left really positive, constructive, fascinating
comments on John's YouTube Red video.
I just installed YouTube Red, I love, I'm
just digging not having advertisements.
There's the thirty day free trial, signed
up for it, and it's - it's just a dream, honestly.
It's just me and my subscriptions.
It's nice, I get what all those people who
have ad-blocker installed, I understand why
you do it.
I've never done it because it's literally
how I pay my employees so I'd feel a little
bad about that, but I totally understand.
At the moment, John, I'm just inspired to
do things that I think are cool, are interesting
that I think people would like.
That's really, I guess that's all we've ever
wanted to do.
And we get to do it.
We're so lucky.
Thanks, everybody.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.
I ate a whole lot of pizza before I made this
video.
I do not feel great.
I feel less than great.